it's totally great we just got too far
ahead of you he's always striving to get
different variation and right there with
you rewriting or improvising with you
how about we say this oh I really love
that can we go back to that version
that's one thing that we've been working
on together a lot is making sure that we
have enough of everything in each
performance so that once he goes to get
everything together he can then finally
decide with what works with the movie
you can give me one give me one more
that is a cliche like you make the movie
three times you've done with the script
and you're like this is the movie and
then you get into production and you're
like all these little discoveries happen
and then you're like we got the movie
and then you go into editorial and the
same thing happens you're like all these
new discoveries happen and then you're
like this is the movie this movie
transformed for me more than any other
film that we've done for the better
sure you want to talk this out don't
stick it in there okay